would you
would you rather if you could date like
you said you don't take broke dudes okay
um
would you rather
date a rich
unattractive dude
or a hot
broke dude
neither well no no
jenny those are the options here no i
mean which one's making me happy
i don't know you're telling me
well okay here let me give you some
details okay give me some details you
gotta give some context here we go here
let's make it rain
rich dude okay takes you out wherever
you want to go you're traveling the
world he's getting you a car you're
living rent-free clearly you're i mean
you're like jewelry handbags living the
life treating you well but he's kind of
busted he's sloppy he doesn't look so
good he's lost his hair like he's just
not an attractive looking dude but he is
making your life
just amazing he's you know whirlwind
relationship he's just not so good
looking however
hot dude like who's your celebrity crush
love channing tatum channing tatum boom
magic mike he's doing the abs he's got
the thing going on hey
he's doing his thing he's hot he's sexy
he's doing his things he's got his you
know his moves he's grooves
but dude still lives at home with his
parents he's broke he can't hold down a
job maybe he's got a little drug problem
i don't know
who would you rather be with you still
didn't answer my question what do you i
just who's making me happy are you
telling me just because he's buying me
gifts doesn't mean i'm happy i could be
miserable in that situation
gotcha hot broke dude was making you
happy you'd pick him rather than the
rich yes okay so happiness is the center
of gravity yes happiness and values
right like maybe the the the let's
assume they're both making you happy
you're happy with both of them but one
you're super attracted to and one you're
super attracted to the lifestyle what's
your pick now jenny you can't say who's
making you happy because you're being
attracted to the personality like you're
making it about lifestyle but it's about
the personality let's say they're both
making you happy
well obviously if they're both making me
happy equally i'm going to choose the
person who's more financially stable
because he's going to give me success
sorry channing tatum
okay
all right nancy
let's throw things your way okay nancy
go with the money
yeah
guys no broke guys no broken so you
you'd rather date the sloppy
rich guy is he funny
let's say it's danny devito
yeah 100 100
okay so i guess essentially what i'm
asking is
is money more important or looks more
important for cause i'll tell you i'm
gonna give you a flip side if you said
hey adam i got a question for you bro
flip it on me would you rather
date a wealthy
billionaire type of woman who's taking
care of you you don't have to work
you're living a great life but she's old
fat and sloppy or
young
hot
gorgeous
fitness model whatever dancer this that
and but she's broke you have to support
her i'd say dude just give me the hawker
i'll figure out the rest like it
wouldn't even be a question
but so do you understand like the
differentiation that we're making right
here now ladies is that guys are
obviously more visual who's making me
happy i don't make myself freaking happy
and then just give me the hot girl
rather than like i don't know i don't
need some old you know rich lady taking
care of me
do you see what we just did there yeah
is there something wrong with a guy
thinking like that
no men are visual creatures okay
nancy is there something wrong with me
thinking like that well because you're
already financially stable too that's
true save that money yeah so the biggest
thing it's like if you're broken
desperate like would you [ __ ] betty
white
you [ __ ] my mom
no rest in peace betty what you're going
to bring up a dead lady bro
i can't think of a another old lady
there's no old ladies that you know of
um
barbara bush oh she died too
i get your point i'm just still pull the
hottest old ladies down there hottest
old ladies all right
you